this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I chose Emory because they had the
largest selection of interesting courses
and when it came down to it I couldn't
choose just one so I applied too many
it's totally different this is real
college life to me like living in a dorm
going to class on my own time being on
my own it's a big transition but I think
by doing this for six weeks it gives you
a little step into college life instead
of that big relief that you take from
high school where is a spot in the
college prep classroom are totally
different than in a high school setting
at first there's a little intimidating
but my professor made us all feel
comfortable she's funny
I heard about every thermocouple trucks
that actually go here being in Charlotte
and Emory is one of the best southern
private institutions I thought this was
a good idea to come join to see what
it's all about
see if I wanted the end of applying here
I wanted to see what it was like to be a
part of a college class with classroom
at Emory what really influenced me to
come here was first log boy setup so I
knew that any type of economic program
or any type of program related to go
Zetas or any have a business school was
going to be good
my roommates I'm China so that's
something I've never experienced before
she's great and no it's definitely a
different walk of life but I'm
experiencing you know coming here and
going everywhere so divers gets really
experienced how other people live and
how they interacted with people and how
they learned you know I can learn from
other people I get to go out on the
weekends with the rest of the program
and Vonda said we get to go to all these
really cool programs like I don't go to
it when all the time so I get to see you
know Piemonte argh
and there's always explodes at the end
of the summer so that's always
it's it's a lot different than high
school and there's like you actually
have to spend time out of class and what
you're learning is actually fun it's
kind of what you choose for me I think
the most surprising thing is that
classes are actually fun I think for at
the class that I'm in right now which is
intro to ethics which is like a
philosophy class it's just really
surprising how like fun the class is
like you'd expect all the friendships
and bondings and stuff to be the most
fun I mean they are fun but I think like
learning in its own has its own rewards
and I think it's I think I really enjoy
like the learning aspect of this like
I've never had this much fun with school
before in my life
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University